welcome to our session today
accelerating insights with the health
analytics platform
i'm marianne slight a product manager on
the healthcare team of google cloud
and with me is my colleague vivian neely
who leads the healthcare
customer engineering specialist
we're going to talk today about clinical
data and the challenges facing health
systems
as they deal with a proliferation of ehr
instances
and ancillary clinical systems so how do
you get your data
into the new standards fire or into the
omop common data model
how do you align your different
modalities of data your different
terminologies of data
how do you create and manage the
pipelines to handle that data
transformation
how do you abstract out structured data
from the unstructured clinical note
and then how do you analyze this data in
a coherent fashion
without needing advanced sql skills
these are the challenges that we're
going to talk about
within this presentation
so let's start off by talking about data
harmonization
how you harmonize all of your different
siloed
data sources into something that's
coherent
and ready for analysis and typically you
might have
several different ehr instances
each of which is configured differently
from the next or perhaps you've acquired
hospitals
and they use a different ehr system than
you do
as well as the ehr data sources you also
have clinical ancillary systems
like lab systems or pharmacy systems and
all of this data harmonized into
something coherent
enables you to analyze more richly your
clinical environment
but it's not just current data that's
important you also need to add on the
historical data
and so what we typically see are
historical data sources
that come to google cloud in the form of
csv
files or databases with incremental or
streaming data
coming in through hl7 version 2 or using
the new fire standard
and that's dealing with the data sources
what you harmonize
too is over on the right hand side some
kind
of target schema and that might be
something like
the fire schemer or it might be
something like the omop
observational common data model that is
used for analyzing data for research
purposes
but most commonly it's some combination
of a standard schema and then custom
extensions in order to support any
investments you've already made
for applications that sit on top of it
and so supporting custom schemas is also
part of our data harmonization suite
now in order to go from your data
sources into your target schema
you typically need to have your data
undergo four
types of transformation the first of
these
is field mappings where perhaps you're
taking
patient underscore id in this database
over here
you've got mrn or medical record number
as the name of the field over in this
data source
and perhaps you've also got member id in
another data source
and you're trying to harmonize it into
say the fire schema
with the patient resource and the
identifier attribute
that's field mappings terminology
mappings
looks at how you label the clinical
concepts
within your data so perhaps you're
capturing your medications
using first data bank in this ehr
but over in cerner you're capturing them
using the maltem
medical terminology and perhaps you want
to harmonize those
into rxnorm these are three different
clinical terminologies
that are used for medications and you
need to be able to harmonize the
concepts
into a coherent single clinical
terminology
for each of your different concept types
units alignment is another step within
data harmonization
because different lab systems produce
the lab test results
with different units often that's just
by a factor of a thousand
but sometimes it's a little more broader
than that as
when a particular lab test its standard
unit of measure
changes at a particular point in time
and in that case
the system needs to understand the point
at which the units
changed from one to another in order
that you can end up
with harmonized data in consistent units
in your analytic target and finally
abstracting out structured data from the
unstructured clinical note and i'll talk
more about that in a moment
so we recently launched our mapping
configuration language which we call
whittle
and we've launched this to open source
so that the entire community can benefit
from this
what the whistle mapping configuration
language does
is it enables you to convert from an
input
in json format into an output
in json format using a mapping
configuration that you've written using
whistle
and what's unique about whistle is that
it supports repeated
and nested structures which of course
are so critical
within support for hr7 version 2 and
within support
for the fire standard it also supports
calls for terminology maps calls for
unit harmonization
and for clinical entity extraction using
natural language processing
and you can create your own user defined
functions
as well now here's an example
of how you might convert an hl7 message
that incorporates the name
and address of a particular health
system
into fire and the gray box at the bottom
that's an example of the whistle mapping
configuration
that you would create to do that when we
launched our whistle data transformation
language
within our open source github repository
we also launched sample maps to get you
started
we included sample maps for two
different message types
of hl7 version 2 map to fire
and we also included sample maps for
mapping from fire
to omop and these are all available
within our github repo
so you've created this whistle mapping
configuration now how do you run it
we have three different ways that you
can run a whistle mapping configuration
create a pipeline and convert your data
the first
is using the google cloud healthcare api
so if you're importing your data from
cloud storage
into the fire api or if you're exporting
your data from the fire api
into bigquery or if you're moving your
data from the hl7 version 2
store into the firestore on google cloud
in each of these cases you can
incorporate
a whistle mapping configuration to
transform the data
as you move it across the second way
is using cloud data fusion which is a
google tool
that is a fully managed service for etl
pipelines and what that allows you to do
is have access to a library of
different pre-configured sources and
connectors and transformations
and a library of pre-configured outputs
or syncs
as well and what's really unique about
cloud data fusion is that this is a
fully managed environment
that does it by drag and drop using a
graphical ui
and that helps you to get away from
managing all of your pipelines with code
into focusing on the actual
transformations that are getting done
and moving you away towards insight and
action
the third way is an open sourced cloud
data flow pipeline
that we launched earlier that converts
this this reference pipeline converts
streaming hr 7 version 2 messages
into fire resources and so that too is
available
on our github repo
now i want to talk about clinical notes
briefly in a bit more detail
this is an example of an icu note it's
very dense
this is just a very small section of
what's typically reams of paper if you
were to print it all out
is reams of paper because a lot of it is
copied
from one note to another it's copied
forward
but the other issue with these kinds of
notes is it's difficult to
find the real wealth of information
that's
buried in this density of text and it's
dense because
there's a lot of different types of
abbreviation
it's also dense with a lot of different
weirdities or oddities in punctuation
because some of this note is actually
generated by the ehr
and then it's not just speaking english
it's also speaking latin
as well and what's challenging about the
clinical note
is when you look at it each of these
different roles
might see something different so when a
physician looks at that note
and says well does this patient have
sepsis
they will be looking at it from a
different perspective than the medical
coder than the cdi nurse and the
clinical quality analyst
the physician is typically looking at it
to say could this patient possibly have
sepsis
because if so he or she is going to do
something different as a result they're
going to follow a different care pathway
whereas the medical coder is looking at
the note to say
does this note justify a diagnosis of
sepsis
because if so that will result in a
different code
on the medical claim they undergo
different training
and these different roles are looking at
it one from the perspective
of discovery the other from the
perspective of compliance
so there are different models for these
different use cases
and clearly one size does not fit all
and so what we are looking at in terms
of clinical entity extraction
are these four areas the first is
abstracting the actual clinical concepts
themselves
the diagnosis the medications the
procedures
the observations and so on the second is
looking at the relations
and the attributes about those key
clinical entities
so for example with medications what was
the dose
what was the route when was it ordered
functional features talks about the
semantic context
of the clinical entities so was that
diagnosis
actually positive for the patient or was
it documented as a rule out
diagnosis did this other diagnosis
impact the patient or instead did it
pertain
to the patient's parent and actually it
should be part of family and medical
history terminology mappings
because when you abstract out this data
it needs to be coded
into one of those clinical terminologies
that the rest of the structured data
described as
i said that one model doesn't fit all
and so we also enable
tuning of these clinical entity
extraction models
using automl an automl allows you to
augment or enrich a model
with a sample of your own data that you
have labeled
for your unique documentation practices
or perhaps you have unique abbreviations
perhaps you've got specific use cases
that you need to support
and automl allows you to tune that model
for your specific circumstance so you've
harmonized your data using our data
harmonization tools
into something coherent now how do you
analyze it
leveraging bigquery enables us to
provide
scalable analytics it's analytic
database
because it's structured as a columnar
database
and it's scalable because it scales
through petabytes
horizontally all of the data is
encrypted
both at rest and in motion by default
and the data is accessible using sql
so all of those business intelligence
tools over on the right hand side
are can access the data within bigquery
using their native capabilities
we also have a number of public data
sets
available on bigquery for you to
integrate into your analysis
as well and we recently launched
the omop common data model as an open
source
github repo on top of bigquery
and further the atlas cohort definition
tool
on top of cloud marketplace in google
cloud
and what that allows you to do is to use
the omop common data model
and analyze the data on bigquery
directly
so understanding the terminologies the
vocabularies
looking at database level statistics
understanding your patient profiles
and looking at your cohort definitions
using
the atlas tool all directly on top of
bigquery
this is an example of the atlas cohort
manager tool
looking at the prevalence of medications
in this data set
and understanding the different
medications and their prevalence
i said we had a number of public data
sets available
this is a subset of the healthcare data
sets that are available on bigquery
the first two are large synthetic data
sets
in two different forms to allow you to
experiment
with these different types of data the
first is fire
using the synthetic data from mitre and
then
second is synpuff using synthetic data
in the omop common data model but as
well as those two
synthetic data sets we have a large
number of curated
current data sets most recently
we've added data sets in the fields of
social determinants of health
and these are kept current every quarter
and take
social determinant data such as income
data snap data homelessness
down to in many cases the county level
so that you can mash this data with your
own
health system data in order to
understand the impact of social
determinants
on your particular population we also
added
the covid19 case data from the new york
times and then there are a number of
other data sets healthcare data sets
that are available and kept current
and we're adding more all the time
finally how do you analyze data
you analyze data using dashboards often
in order to generate action so what are
the decisions that you want to make
on the basis of that analysis well
dashboards and in particular our locker
offering
enables you to look at key performance
indicators from your health system
in this example i'm looking at
readmission rates
mortality and average length of stay
across my entire
hospital system obviously i can look at
that over time
i can drill into specific facilities
over on the right hand side
you can see that i'm looking at some of
the key diagnoses and procedures
those costly chronic often comorbid
conditions
and looking at where i have
potential to improve those key
performance indicators
and i can drill into that in more detail
and if i drill into for example
ami then i can see for my ami
patients those on the right hand side
who are most at risk of bouncing back
with a readmission and that risk score
has been generated using a machine
learning model directly within bigquery
using a bqml
model that takes advantage of some of
the public data sets
that we looked at earlier some of the
social determinant data sets
but also takes into account things like
the number of comorbidities
and the discharge date relative to now
as well as the age
of the patient and so finally
these are some of the demonstration of
the
the correlations between the risk score
and some of the social determinant data
in these examples household income data
and snap enrollment data
so we've talked about the capabilities
of the healthcare analytics platform
let's talk about one specific use case
and that's a clinical data cloud for
fire
because increasingly we're seeing fire
in use in health systems
as its central repository real-time
repository
for clinical data because of its long
longitudinal patient record support and
so
in this example here you harmonize your
data
into fire using the tools that we've
talked about for data harmonization
you make the data available in analytics
on bigquery
you store the data natively in the
healthcare firestore as part of the
healthcare api
all of this sits on top of the data
protection suite
which encompass our support for hipaa
best practices
and we also enable access to that data
through the fire application layer that
includes smart on fire
and also apogee and now i'm going to
hand it over to my colleague vivian
neely
who's going to talk about the
architecture
thank you marianne so when we think
through how
data flows through this system there are
five conceptual steps
it takes to get to a
point where users can surface it to
applications or perhaps
other analytics use cases as marianne
discussed
there are a vast amount of data sources
that can be ingested
from ehr data to patient generated data
even with imaging data all of these
different source systems
result in different products being
utilized for data ingestion
our healthcare api for example takes
three different modalities
fire dicom and hl7 while as
something like our cloud storage or blob
storage
product can handle a wide variety of
data
that may be coming from data warehouses
or
patient or other data sources truly
the data harmonization layer is really
where the magic happens
all the aspects of harmonization are
handled in this step
including utilizing the whistle
transformation language
in order to get your data to a common
data model it can persist in
while this architecture highlights
utilizing cloud data fusion for
harmonization as marianne discussed
users can also leverage our google cloud
healthcare api
or cloud data flow as the infrastructure
to do
these transformations once it's in a
persistent layer
whether that be in the healthcare api
under fire
or perhaps in bigquery we really move to
the enrichment stage
and this is where users get to explore
their data and drive insights from their
data
the users can connect with the plethora
of other google cloud products
such as our ai platforms or ai platform
notebooks
which is really just a manager managed
jupyter notebook
we even allow for applications that are
hosted on our marketplace
for vm images to be able to use some of
the
other applications that are be
publishing by other institutions
with on within your data set
the second architecture that i go over
is really more of a technical
architecture
of the flow of the data as i discussed
the various different source systems
result
in various different ingestion processes
so while
batch data or historical data might come
in on on cloud storage
real-time data comes in usually
within hl7 v2 or perhaps device data
that's going to be handled on a
transactional database and may land in
the healthcare api store
or one of our other application based
products such as our app engine the
transformation and harmonization step
here is happening with cloud data fusion
and then there is a various different
ways that it can
the data can be handled metadata can
appear one way
and other data such as your analytics
data your de-identified data
can be surfaced through bigquery and
utilized with products such as our
private catalog
i'm now going to show you a demo of the
solution we discussed
so now we're going to be demonstrating
that end-to-end architecture that we
just talked through
from an input in this case an hl7
message
to transformation storing it in a
firestore
and exporting it to bigquery what's
going to be sending our hl7 messages
is a tool called simulated hospital
google has open
sourced this tool and essentially what
it does
is it sends synthetic hl7 messages
to whatever application you're looking
to test
it allows you to choose how many
pathways per hour
for this case i'm going to turn it all
the way up for the demo
this source code can be found at google
sim hospital
we're going to hop to the pipeline this
pipeline has been built in data fusion
data fusion's great for users who are
more familiar with
ui based pipeline building it's
running on top of dataproc or really our
managed hadoop
product you can see here we have plugins
and inputs and outputs for each of the
step of the pipeline
our hl7 store pub sub if we look into
this we can figure out
which subscription we are listening to
what the naming is
and truly where it's coming from
we're currently at 200 hl7 messages
i nope hop to 201 so as we're going
through the demo
you can see and fundamentally watch each
of the messages go through the steps
and how long it takes for them to get to
the
fire store and be able to write
these mapping boxes are calling our
whistle
code what whistle is is we have open
sourced
a configuration language that allows for
arbitrary json to arbitrary json
we have also open sourced reference
mappings
for hl7 to fire and we are utilizing
those reference mappings during this
demonstration
so what that means is you can pull both
this
pipeline as well as our reference
mappings
to be able to automatically spin up or
quickly spin up a hl7 to fire pipeline
in your environment
we've stored those on a gcs bucket you
can see here
and over in the properties for the
firestore it will tell you
where the firestore is located the
dataset name
and firestore id we can also look at the
documentation and the metrics to see
how frequently data is writing to the
firestore in this pipeline
so if we hop over we want to look a
little bit more into this
mapping whistle configuration
first though i'm going to go into
bigquery
this is where the final data is being
written so from the firestore it is
being
exported and streamed into bigquery
it is falling into this fire data set
you can see each of the resources
creates a table within bigquery
so just to test that we are indeed
sending data i'm going to run
a count of the number of observations in
my data set
we're currently at eighteen thousand
nine hundred and twelve
so i'm going to hop over to our jupiter
notebook demonstration
and go back to this just to prove my
honesty
of the streaming real time capabilities
of the pipeline
so here in jupiter notebooks we have
also open sourced
what and fundamentally a ui for users to
be able to
understand evaluate and reference
against their whistle code
it also does some fire validation that
i'll walk through as well
for the input the hl7 since
whistle is a arbitrary json to arbitrary
json
logic the hl7 messages that are
traditionally
text-based messages go through our hl7
parser to then be transformed into a
json object
so i'm going to be loading that json
object from
google cloud storage into our
notebook here we can look at this this
is an
adt message the msh header is here
and this is how the parsing logic does
um
treats the message in each of the
segments
so now we're going to actually go
transform that message
this particular magic command lets users
execute the scripts you can display it
in real time you can then use it to go
store as another variable it will show
you what the fire bundle looks like
at the end of your whistle code
so we're going to be processing the adt
we've defined that in
previous um in the open source code that
i'll
show in a minute i'll go ahead and run
this
so you can see it's creating a
transactional bundle
with several different entries this
particular one
is requesting so it's going to be the
request method is a put to the firestore
and it's putting an organization id
each of these functions that i'm calling
are stored in various different
areas of the open source code so
messages
for example we can see here's the
code that's defining how to transform
your adt message
we also have the segments whistles so
this is the code that was defining that
msh header
all of this again is available open
source on our git repository
so we can go back here and now um
test out whether or not that fire
resource we just created
is actually going to be uh written and
valid for the firestore
so we're going to transform another
message
and then we're going to check its
validation
so this is an invalid fire resource i
actually did that on purpose just to
demonstrate
the ability for us to on the fly
make changes that then can be affecting
of the validation
so hopefully when we try this again we
can see here
it is indeed a valid source so now it's
going to be writing to the firestore
and everything that we do on this
jupyter notebook actually
changes the google cloud storage and
whistle code you're utilizing so this
can be a very valuable tool
for folks who are more familiar with the
notebook like interface
again all of this is open sourced at
google cloud platforms git repository
at healthcare data harmonization
so now if we hop back into bigquery
let's run this command again
great it went up um and so you can see
the streaming results of this
is um in real time on how many
observations it is actually writing into
the bigquery
data set now for fire for those who are
familiar it can be a pretty complicated
uh data format and data standard to
utilize
so a little bit more complicated of a
query can be found here
essentially what i'm going to be doing
is pulling some patients from the
patient resource
since the patient or all resources are
nested and have arrays in them you have
to use this safe
offset command within bigquery it allows
you
to see a flat view of patient ids
phones birthdays addresses things like
this
now for those who don't want to write
such a
complicated query against bigquery or
maybe are just not as familiar with sql
we had a recent acquisition looker
who can the semantic layer within looker
actually can understand the fire data
standard
and write the queries for you so it can
take that complicated nests
and arrays within unnested on the fly
and create beautiful visualizations for
this complicated data model
here we have an example of a patient
that is utilizing looker and their data
is stored in the fire data standard
so you can see they're from
massachusetts 80 years old
this is an encounter timeline the larger
diamond is
the longer the encounter was and you can
kind of see their vitals over time
this could be effective patient
management for doctors or clinicians to
be able to
understand what their patient looks like
across the
in the continuum of care
we then can also go over to more of an
administrative view
which is allowing for us to visualize
how many patients is going through a
system
what's the average length of stay or
readmission rate
as well as an overview of your
population
for any of these particular statistics
we actually have the ability to drill
into them
so i have the ability to drill into and
see each of the patients that are making
up that statistic
if i'm interested in this particular
patient i have the ability to follow up
with him
or see his overview which is that very
similar
dashboard to the last one we were seeing
for each of the individual patients
sucker can be a great tool to abstract
that complicated data model into a layer
that
you are able to drive meeting from
gain insights from as well as even do
some
machine learning modeling here thank you
so much for coming
for more information check out our
harmonization
github repo and contact your sales rep
on how to get started
you